PROBLEM.
THAT'S JUST THE WAY HE IS.
>> WERENSKI, THE
NET.
ROSLOVIC.
LONG SHOT KICKED BY SKATING
WELL.
KAAPO KAKKO, MOVES IN AND
RANGERS' THIRD HOME
>> A SHOT THAT WAS DEFLECTED ON
THE WAY.. BRUIN.
CENTERS.
SAVE.
THAT SHOT WAS BLOCKED.
>> THATNS' BIG SAVE.
AND THEN OUT OF THE NET.
HERE COMES THE FIRST ONE
>> PASS OFF THE SKATES. FIRST P.
BOTH TEAMS AND OUT.
ROBINSON.
SAVED WAY.
WERENSKI.
PARTIALLY BLOCKED.
GOOD PLAY BACK.
THEN FOX FORCES WERENSKI WHO
MOVED UP ON THE
AND SAVE MADE BY ANDREW
PEEKE.
>> LAFRENIERED, KURALY CARRIED
TO THE CORNER, TROUBA GOT A
PIECE O HIGH MIDDLE OPEN.
GUESS WHO TO FIND
HIM ALL THE WAY ON THE OTHER
SIDE.
WHO IN FRONT.
ARAR COLUMBUS.
ON GOALS, STEERED ROONEY.
ROONEY IN THE A YEAR
OR FRONT.
HOFMANN.
AND CHECKED BY NEMETH.
WERENSKI.
VORACEK.
SHOT BLOCKED.
AND GOT THE LEFT
SKATE ON
LAFRENIERE AND SAVE.
TRICKY SHOT AS LAFRENIERE TRIED
TO GO O PASS TO THE
MIDDLE, TO THE BOARDS, TO THE
MIDDLE.
LAFRENIERE M NET.
PASS ACROSS. NET.
PANANAHIRD ROBINSON.
SAVE.
REBOUND,EFT LEG.
GETS ALL THE WAY ACROSS. SAVED.
REBOUNDSAW LUNDKVIST DO THAT FO5
4-0 RANGERS.
AND KREIDER DOES
WHAT A DEFLECTION.